i wonder if we could start with those
gdp figures obviously they have now
dropped but a contraction of 0.3 percent
not what people were expecting certainly
not what people were wanting is it now
time for the government to stop
maintaining that this is the fastest
growing economy in the g7
well the truth is that as we all come
out of the pandemic globally there are
pressures on supply chains and a lot of
inflationary pressure around the world
principally of course caused by that
spike in the gas price so we've known
for some time that this is going to be a
challenge but it doesn't take away from
the fact that actually we were
successful at getting ourselves through
the pandemic the fastest vaccine roll
out and that put our economy in a strong
position to recover we've got
unemployment that's at record lows the
lowest it's been since at least 1974 but
of course there are some real challenges
ahead and these gdp figures of course
are a reminder of those challenges
um let's talk then on one of the major
political political issues of the day
and i promise we will come on to to the
announcement on your brief in a moment
that the the northern ireland protocol
at the government tabling the bill today
to try and solve some of the problems
with it can you explain to me and indeed
to joshua rosenberg at the legal the
legal commentator how you can break an
international agreement the arrangement
that we have with the european union in
the form of the protocol and it not be a
breach of international law
well look obviously when the bill is
introduced we'll set out the legal you
know basis for that and the attorney
general
has uh has been involved closely with
this and has uh given you know given her
advice on it but the the crucial thing
is the import we have we have to make
this northern ireland protocol work
properly because at the moment it's a
it's a serious threat to the belfast
good friday agreement and you know we
don't have the inter-ministerial
committees meeting which is supposed to
bring together politicians on both sides
of the irish border store months not
sitting and trade from gb to northern
ireland has been severely affected so we
have to get a durable solution to this
we've been trying very hard with the
european union to get them to discuss
they're refusing to even change their
mandate and so we have to basically give
clarity
about what the protocol means how it
should be interpreted only the uk can do
that
but just in terms of of the action that
you're taking today do you not accept
the fact that everyone wants torment to
be back up and running as soon as
possible but do you not accept the fact
that given that a majority of the
assembly members that would be sitting
at storm want do not want you to take
this action that actually think that you
know business in northern ireland has
got to grips the protocol in what way is
that democratic
well actually um brandon lewis has been
working with politicians uh right across
uh ireland and all of the parties and
they all recognize that if the protocol
were to be fully implemented it really
wouldn't work and you know you say that
people are grappling with it have gotten
used to it it's important to recognize
that most of the provisions aren't yet
being implemented so there are some
standstill provisions that we have which
means we're not actually doing any
checks at the moment uh when it comes to
um uh products going from gb to to
northern ireland there are many other
grace periods that are only temporary
and what we need is some longer-term
permanent solutions and that's what this
bill would set out
so so how's the have the dup committed
then on the basis of the bill that will
be tabled later on today to return to
power sharing
and my understanding is that they
haven't but obviously there's a parallel
set of discussions there we i very much
want them to uh to get back to power
sharing they're very clear they want to
see um you know some progress made and
that we at least get this bill
introduced and started but i know we
obviously be working very hard
to get them back in place they want to
see the issues around the protocol
settled and that's what this
government's determined to do
i i do want to ask a little bit about
the the cbi an organization which is
which has made a number of comments
about the northern ireland protocol over
well over the course of its lifetime
tony danker has been accused of
interfering in the government's plans to
deal with the protocol a couple of your
colleagues briefing the papers along
those lines do you share that view do
you think the cbi should you know sit
down and shut up
well look i work um very closely with
lots of different businesses and the
truth is that most of the major
retailers like marx and spencers and
tesco and others who are sending quite
complex composite loads of loras to
northern ireland they know that the
protocol if implemented in its in its um
uh full full way wouldn't it wouldn't
allow their business models to really
continue so uh businesses generally do
want us to sort this problem out
obviously cbi is a lobby group it can it
can set out its position um but we've
obviously
got access to the sort of right legal
advice as to what we're doing and we
obviously have a much more knowledge and
we we draw
um we draw a comment from a much wider
pool of businesses than the cbi
represents
at the rwanda repatriation flights uh
again heading towards the court of
appeal today it seems likely there will
be some form of legal action you know
over the coming weeks and months in
terms of all of this i mean one question
that keeps getting it keeps coming up to
me is why haven't you legislated to
allow the government to do this why have
you not legislated you know
passed a bill that for example you said
ignore these parts of the human rights
act ignore these parts of the modern
slavery act and move forward i mean
you've got the majority to do it so i i
don't understand why you haven't
well because we again the home secretary
has looked to this government lawyers
that looked at this
and actually we think what we propose is
in fact entirely um you know is entirely
lawful and uh indeed of course there was
a court challenge
last week that the court upheld our
right to take this step and the reason
we're doing it is it's very important
people understand this you know we have
a tragic high number of deaths of people
trying to cross the channel and we've
got people smugglers that are exploiting
that misery and putting lies at risk
and we've got to to send a very clear
signal that
you know this this isn't something we're
going to allow to continue so as well as
yes interrupting uh those gangs we have
to make clear that they're not going to
be able to just necessarily come into
the uk that we will process some uh
in a country at a center in rwanda so
that we can actually try and stop the
demand in order to stop putting lives at
risk that's why we're doing this
what level of confidence though do you
have that that plane will take off with
more than one person on it
well look there was a legal challenge
obviously uh in respect of some of them
last week my understanding is that that
legal challenge fails of course lawyers
will continue you know to make these uh
these sorts of noises but we put in
place an agreement
with rwanda i think it was um a very big
step forward when the home secretary
brittany patel secured that agreement uh
it's something actually that
the governments and oppositions have
talked about as a potential solution for
a very long time going back some 20
years and um it is it is we think the
right thing to do in order to try to
address this problem of people putting
their lives at risk uh risk and putting
their lives in the hands of um terrible
people smugglers
um mrs i am nothing if not a man of my
word so let's talk about the food
strategy that is being launched today
and i wonder if you could speak very
directly to henry dimbleby the the man
whose recommendations the government
looked at and moved forward with some of
them of course he's on the program just
a little bit later today his complaint
is twofold that half of what he
recommended has been ignored and
specifically on health clearly we know
there's an issue with obesity
particularly in adults massively in
children at the moment there's nothing
there was nothing really there on health
according to mr dimbleby how would you
respond to that
well of course i i've spoken directly to
henry henry dimbley about this in fact
we take forward the vast majority of his
recommendations and so on health and
obesity uh for instance he recommended a
data partnership that was his flagship
recommendation uh we're taking that out
because business has access to far
better consumer data than government uh
ever can and of course we've already
introduced many things in this space
we've introduced new
requirements on point of sale
restrictions so that high fat salt and
sugar goods can't be uh given prominent
display in supermarkets that is already
but why not consult in sugar attacks why
not the salt and sugar tax it's clearly
something the government has considered
in the past
well um
we're already doing so we have used it
where it's appropriate where it works on
for instance um reformulation of soft
drinks where you can actually
take sugar out quite simply but there
are many other products like chocolate
like certain cakes where sugar is an
ingredient to those and there aren't
actually any replacements for it so we
need to look at different approaches
like maybe portion size and that's
something that we're considering and we
also
though it's important to recognize have
put in place these points of sale
restrictions that's already driving some
reformulation and it's already driving
changes in in portion size so
supermarkets are reacting to this agenda
by what we've already put in place and
of course we've put in place these
things since henry dimbleby made his
original recommendations
george it's always good to have you on
the program thanks very much for joining
us thank you very much